are you feeling all your interviews if
so this is the game for you
click the zoom link if you wish to
participate in the game
oh i heard something
where is it coming from sir you're on a
zoom call um
try holding alt and then press tab
yeah you probably have your zoom window
minimized
oh hello
oh thank you
[Music]
yeah whatever man
wait
eric
why aren't you like the ceo of blinder
what are you doing here i literally saw
you on force 30 under 30. aren't you
like really rich
let's talk later
welcome to the game
due to covet 25 restrictions and
budgetary issues we couldn't bring you
on site so for the 2025 game it will be
held remotely please open the package we
delivered it contains the uniform we
will be rowing oh [ __ ] free swag it's
not company swag it's going to be a
patagonian vest i know it no it's not
everyone here will participate in six
different games those who win all six
games
will receive
[Applause]
a job
oh
that's it a stable nine to five job and
45 million shares of stock options you
can purchase which you can only exercise
after four years
passive income no
i want 50 million
i don't think you have the luxury to
counter offer right now mr wang i just
got a competing offer from another squid
game and they're offering 48 million and
21 vacation days and no offense
it will look better on my resume if i
went with them
okay 50 million
before we start this game we want to
present the sponsor of this year's game
who will be sponsoring the winners prize
again because of budgetary issues this
year the sponsor is
nordvpn
oh yeah baby i loved our vpn if you want
a good vpn that protects the things you
buy the searches you make and the
websites you visit check out nordvpn not
only it encrypts your traffic you can
use it to change your location and watch
shows that are only shown in specific
countries
if you're interested there is a black
friday deal going on right now where you
can get 73 percent off the two-year plan
plus one month free get it at
northvpn.com
joma now back to the game
today you will be playing the first game
the first game to be played is called
fizz buzz
you will be writing the program fizzbuzz
in assembly
oh [ __ ]
we have assigned an ide to you you can
only code during the green light you
have five minutes you may now begin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] wright's calling assembly
[Music]
player one completed her challenge oh
right
wait wait wait wait 24 51 126 eliminated
[Music]
wait what
you have to minimize your id every time
the song reaches the end
[Music]
[Music]
oh you've got to be kidding me
[Music]
oh my god no battery
seriously [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] these are tactile switches
[Music]
oh thank god linears
what are you doing you don't have much
time left dude i don't know how to write
assembly code
remember what you learned in your
computer architecture class
remember
remember what you've learned
do you see it
no you don't dude i was a coding boot
camp student
oh [ __ ]
okay listen put 0 101 3 5 and zero in
temporary registers
write a procedure to check if it's
divisible by five write another one to
check if it's not divisible by any and
write one that just inserts a new line
your main move to check if it's
divisible by three make the procedures
call each other one after the other
repeat that until t-0 comes t-1
[Music]
[ __ ] there's not much time left i have
to submit my code
wait no no
i'm sorry
good luck
okay
[Music]
you